[Music]
hello everyone i'm grand master dennis
borsch and this
is a grand master's choice this time
i'm going to talk about the isolated
queen
on positions now when i first started
playing chess
it was mostly botvinnik games i thought
okay how am i ever going to get
these classical queens gambit
structures where you have an isolated
pawn so i was wondering
wondering and here is my first game
where i played
hoffman in hungary so this is my game
versus michael
hoffman and i realized hey there is one
way to do it through the four systems
now
what if i was a d4 player it's much
easier to get there
c4 takes e3
e5 and already
you get the isolated pawn structure
which usually
leads to very lively play this is just
one
stray example of how easy it is to get
an isolated pawn
in d4 openings in e4 however it's much
trickier
however there's one trick here c5
c3 and here actually you get to play
positions with an isolated pawn
or kind of the stepsister of it all
the hanging pawns hello there people
so this will be the main topic of the
day
c3 sort of enticing
black to play d5 which was the
most popular at the moment at that time
d5 takes queen takes d5
d4 e6 knight f3
knight f6 bishop e3
c takes d4 c takes d4 and
we kind of get into these iqp structures
that i've was kind of hoping for
based on those fantastic but winning
games i've just studied at that time
also as a side note
here we do get the typical
hanging pawn structure
and even though you no longer have an
isolated pawn
the d-pawn takes the place
i mean the c pawn takes the d-pawn's
place
and that means that the c pawn will be
the
eternal target in these type of
positions
but in this game my opponent played
knight f6 and that is something that you
need to know
if you play the c3 sicilian and you're
aiming for
iqp's e5 knight d5
d4 c takes knight f3 e6
cd b6 now everybody and
their great grandson plays knight c6
bishop d3 and d6 so this is the main
line
however my opponent like playing it with
b6
b6 is actually a very normal move but
it has one downside to it it is very
much time consuming and creates
threats i mean creates potential targets
along
this diagonal
c3 immediately forcing some action
and again we get this semi
hanging pawn structure in c7
ship d2 d6 so black is sort of
marking time with this these moves queen
c7
d6 knight d7 so let's just pause here
for a second
how can we try and take advantage of
that there's actually two ways we can
do so
note that my opponent's king is still in
the center
it is actually two more moves till
castling
so this might be a good chance to attack
the king
so bishop d3 is actually a logical move
knight d7 and here comes the critical
point
dear viewers what would you do in this
specific case
now there's an interesting point in the
chat saying they avoid
iqp and hanging pawns because it is
risky and
indeed it is somewhat strategically
risky
but if you get the dynamics right then
you will get
very very good play with either
with the isolated pawn or against it
so just notice that black does have some
pressure on the e5 pawn
and a bit on c3 so bishop f4 is a no-no
at the moment you'd lose the pawn
so canceling is an interesting idea
however it doesn't really pinpoint the
fact that this king is still stuck in
the center
and it doesn't really take advantage of
that fact
which we can actually use to our benefit
d5 is a little bit much
it's an interesting move but you know
it's too spicy spicy is good
but ghost pepper is just too much
so sometimes you wonder what your
opponent is about to do
and i'll tell you straight up black
wants to go bishop e7 and castles
but if you set up a good old tactical
trick
that won't be possible
bishop e4 there's bishop b b7
and then with every exchange
the position gets more and more
comfortable for black
always look out for weak squares
there's a weak square on f7 and there's
a semi loose rook on a8
indeed knight g5
not saying it's deadly but it does force
black's hand and naturally they'll go
bishop
b7 just to stop any queen f3 ideas
hitting both the rook and the pawn on f7
now people usually tell you castle
castle as quickly as possible
but sometimes it's better to set up
threats
that your opponent has to react to than
just
mundanely castle when i g5 my opponent
obviously just played bishop b7
but here comes the big dilemma
this spawns hanging this spawn's hanging
can we defend both of them do we even
care
no we don't care we castle we play
like a madman and that's actually one of
the
ways of playing iqp positions
you are going to play like a madman you
are going
all in for peace activity yes
i'm given up a pawn however
that again further
further kind of points out the fact that
the king will be stuck
in the middle for a bit longer d takes
e5
and knowing that the next move should be
easy peasy
you seg the pawns because you want to
gain time
and as long as your opponent's king is
in the center that is
usually a good source of counter play
now knight f7 is a brave move
however i think i would just capture
back
and hide like sir
brave robin and
unfortunately i don't think we have
enough to checkmate
and if push comes to shove black can
always play queen c6
so it's not quite ripe yet for a
sacrifice sadly
but caveman-like chess is definitely
welcome
in this position
is c for caveman enough i reckon not
it's not caveman enough at all
f4 makes sense it's not the move i
played
but it's definitely caveman-ish enough
you might want to start
rolling with that pawn however
caveman 101 is queen h5
saying hey i'm gonna checkmate you over
there
my opponent actually reacts with g6
and with these weaknesses e6 and g6
it is time for me to set up tactical
tricks
so the next move is sorta crucial
i know some of you already are itching
to sacrifice some pieces
but you do have to prepare these ideas
before they could
actually work
yep nathan is correct
queen h3 eyeing
that e6 pawn and sometimes the f7 as
well
yep the reason i didn't go queen g4 here
because they can oftentimes run into not
f6 ideas and you never want to
lose a tempe when the tempe can prove
decisive
so queen h3 is nice and pleasant
because you are just getting ready for
some sacrifices
now my opponent got scared and did not
really want to face
any sort of sacrifices so then go bishop
g7
instead played bishop e7
so when you're burning all your bridges
development becomes an important
issue
so next move is simple but very
important
in the great scheme of things
so never forget that when you're going
for an attack
you still need some reinforcements when
you'll be running short of supplies
you guys are giving away supplies with
these sacrifices
on e6 and f7
but we're not quite ready that yet we
don't
have the convoy there
to help us when we're running short on
supplies
rookie one yes bring in
the tanks bring in the tanks so if e
takes d4
it is time to fire a wave at knight
takes f7
if king takes queen takes e6 and
everything is burning and it's just
going to be checkmate
pretty soon after bishop h6
it is near impossible to stop
now he takes d4 did not happen but he
takes d for just
shows how dangerous this attack can get
if black is not careful like play the
good move bishop d5 sync hey
i don't want any of your business of
sacrificing on f7 or e6
however my opponent still cannot castle
because of the
trivial queen h7 checkmate just for show
this is a checkmate you don't want to
miss
even though i've seen super grand
masters fall
some made him once so you never know
you can always learn meaning once bishop
d5
and here comes everybody's favorite f4
so even then down the pawn
all of my pieces are ready to pounce
and f4 actually helps activate my rook
on f1
ship takes g5 f takes g5
bishop c4
and here comes another dilemma
are we forced to part with the bishop
bear
some say no okay
but if we do is there a way we could
continue with the attack
why bishop c4 i think that really has to
do with the fact that my opponent
wanted to solidify the position
now takes does not win it turns out
because after queen f3 there's castles
and
both the rook on a8 and the pawn on f7
is defended
so that does not win the game but i
realize that hey
take stakes d takes e5 this is not at
all bad
now black could consider some wild
choices of castling long
but my opponent was fairly conservative
and went
short and seemingly my attack died down
but this is the moment you've got to
come up with
an extra plan that you don't think you
have in the position
and again this plan wouldn't have worked
without me actually bringing in the
rooks to the game
yep rook f4
we are using this
square it's a way of getting
that rover going f4
queen c5 king h1 and
sadly for black he'll have to take on e5
otherwise i'll just go rook h4 and just
massacre on the h file there's not much
that can't happen there so my opponent
took on h5 i mean e5
rook h4 but here comes the typical
saving move
for my opponent
which is typical in sicilian structures
and i assume
for you dear viewers this will be just a
split second
to find the right move but still
it's a good thing to test your defensive
skills it's important too
because this is the easiest and
the nicest way of defending against
doubling and tripling on the h
file h5 of course
the typical way of closing it down and
white
either doesn't have the time to get g4 n
and now
in this case the knight would just
capture
or is forced to take on h6 like in this
case i
took and i think my opponent made a
mistake here
a mistake that well i don't think it's
decisive
but is something
should have been done and i think the
move is king h7
that would have liked better for my
opponent just stopping
this pawn and you know it's relatively
comfortable over
there
but hoffman played rook d8
rook d4 i'm tempting my opponent to
capture
although it is clear it's taboo i would
check here first
king here c takes d4 forking
takes bishop c3 and again
long range pieces win the game
black loses the knight and white wins
rook d4 but here comes knight c6
and this is the critical moment
white will need to find a way to get in
black's position otherwise strategically
black is winning and that's actually one
of the things
with the iqp or isolated queen spawn
structures
you've got to be resolute
they'll be like a window of time where
you can break through with your attack
and if you don't do it that was your
last chance
and that's it so you always have to be
vigilant in that sense
so it is white to move and play
queen h4 yep that is the key move
pinpointing the fact that hey i am
coming in
over here but the first question is what
if black takes on d4
at night
queen f5 is gg i mean queen f6
excuse excuse me it's gg but
what about knight f5 and suddenly it's
not
as gg as you might think it is
i mean it's gg but black wins
and not white
h7
yeah call the ambulance for the wrong
guy exactly
king h8 if king g7 white
just checks here and collects the whole
house
if you go here just queen f6 takes in
queen g7
what is gg gg is good game
is a good game
so here the very very nice move is
bishop g5
and bishop f6 is quite brutal
if you go knight f5 i check
here and queen h6 and there is no way of
stopping queen g7 checkmate
like his upper rook has fairly pretty
pieces
but ugly things are about to happen on
g7
and if black goes f6 takes
takes and you lose all your rooks and
the game
as well it's a sad day you lose both
rooks
and the game takes and
queen d8 and this is obviously winning
as right is up in exchange
so knight d4 was not working because of
this
very nice idea of bishop g5
and g7 queen h6
therefore my opponent decided to go
queen e7
instead
so here you'd think that the situation
is getting better for black
not really not really
although you do have to create some
weaknesses in black's position
how can we do that
first off we'll stop this
idea of king h7 for good and play the h7
check
engage it
and now we have to be precise
precise to the core
ship g5 okay
bishop g5 f6
what will happen in that case
maybe then take on d8 actually i did the
reverse i took on d8 first
saying that i am pretty much fine with
getting two rooks in an open position
and probably the difference is the
following f6
takes you can actually capture back with
the knight which i didn't
want and when i took here on d8 you
can't really take with the knight
because your queen needs protection so
queen takes d8
bishop g5 and i literally force my
opponent to capture with the queen
also just in passing
bishop g5 would when the game circus d8
is not an option either
ship g5 f6 bishop h6
rook e8 and again it seems like the
worst is over
for black however
these pawns on e6 f6 and g6 became
mighty weak
in the position
so one last accurate move and we'll
sweep it all
now rookie six is a little bit brave
so i wouldn't go that far
i mean we have a good position we don't
have to go
or gung-ho in this position
in a mate so we can't really go bishop
g7 because they take
and that square is heavily protected so
unfortunately that does not work
but rook f1 does work and that was the
whole point of my maneuver
chasing this rook away and now i have
a target on the f6 pawn
g5 queen e4
partly hitting this knight on c6 but
mostly
eyeing the g6 square so i can go bishop
g7 and checkmate
again you could also notice
that queen d7 queen g6
not only will i have queen f6 ideas
ship g7 will also threaten queen take c8
ideas next
now this is actually a very tough
position my opponent did put up some
tough resistance knight e5 but this
immediately runs into a slight tactic it
did defend against
knight g6 and it's no longer hanging
but after bishop takes g5 you're losing
the pawn
and the position is sort of collapsing
knight d7 queen g6
point being if you capture i have rook
f7
and the mate is quite difficult to stop
queen e7 boom goes the rook
you can't take it because you lose your
queen
look f8 you just drop back to f3
again you can't capture because it's
queen g8 mate
take again losing a winning game is the
easiest thing in life
so you better stay vigilant and give
mate first
rook f3 queen e8 queen takes c8 and here
my opponent resigned
because after vocab 7 there's nowhere
this knight can go
and if the knight goes to c5 it's bishop
f6
checkmate
yep it's important to do so so this is
kind of one of my first experiences with
the c3 sicilian and this
iqp type of structures
you have to be resolute and you have to
keep attacking
now i am going to show one of my other
games
a bit later but what would
this whole thing be without a kasparov
game
him playing a true iqp
style position
this game was played between gary
kasparov
and lev success a training match
in 70s 80s so
let's take a look again
as you might notice it's much easier to
get these isolated pawn structures
from the d4 openings
this is the nimso knight e2
d5 takes takes and this is a little bit
different
than the usual ones that you get
from a normal structure here white
actually has the
bishop pair which kind of
gives a slightly better position for
white
so this is actually a better position
even from the start
for kasparov however it is still
an iqp position take stakes knight c6
bishop e3
castle castle so at those times
they still felt that hey this is still
an isolated pawn
so this should be cannibal for black
however it turns out to be that white
has
so much counter play because of the
bishop pair
and the extra space that the two bishops
give
that is actually much much better for
white
b6 and let's start from this position
white has lots of development
as i see in chat already mentioning that
that's
very much correct white is in the lead
so if you have that much of a lead you
need to convert it
in some way shape or form
and we have to decide are we going to
try to attack in the center or
go for an attack actually surprises me
i thought that this game was played in
the 70s 80s return
turns out to be in the 1990s
things you learn
now you can play d5 but that is sort of
the dilemma
does d5 actually help you
now again something to mention that
black
not only doesn't have the bishop bear
but also lags
space meaning it's much harder to move
and when you have less space you the
you're the one who's preferring
exchanges as not the one
who has more
you're wondering about a move such as g4
now that's a brave move but it's not a
great idea
right here especially as black snacks
move is
particularly likely to be bishop b7
so here kasparov decided against
exchanging
because that would kind of diminish his
advantage
and meant for queen f3
you can't take the pawn that rook is
hanging
bishop b7 and again d5
no longer works because you run into
knight e7 ideas
and these pins and attacks
so that means kasparov had to switch
gears
he no longer can play in the center
so he goes for the king queen h3
seems like a legit idea however
black could consider taking the d pawn
therefore
kasparov played bishop d3 first if they
take
then the bishop is hanging rook c8
and remember my game versus hoffman
never forget to develop your pieces
same goes in this position
never forget to develop
rook d1 yes
black can face queen h3 later
but hey rook on d1 can never be a wrong
thing
it defends the d4 pawn and can even
support d5 breaks in the long run
rook c7 nice little move by psukis
over defending the bishop and preparing
this idea
of re-routing the knight via knight e7
knight d5
ala karpov karpov like this maneuvers
with the knight and actually leads to
fairly comfortable positions
when black has the bishops as well but
here
black is already somewhat in the back
foot because of the lack of the dark
squared bishop
now queen h3 eyeing the h7
pawn knight e7
and this is like a typical tabia
position
most of the time you would see a bishop
on e7
instead and not a knight however
that doesn't change the fact that
kasparov
will have to act resolutely here so
let's
get resolute here viewers let's get
resolute
yes rar bishop g5 immediately
you're pinning the knights and you are
setting up threats against the king
subsakis has no time to regroup with
knight d5
because in that case you lose
bishop f6 and queen h7 is winning
and has to commit this knight to this
square on g6
now knight g6 is not necessarily such a
bad move
but if black could choose
he definitely put the knight on d5
instead
now with these knights being on g6 and
f6
the mate is rather unlikely
so here kasparov switches gears and
plays queen g3
which is actually a multi-purpose move
not only does kasparov eye
that c7 rook he is kind of
winking at ideas such as of h4h5
and maybe h6
not that it necessarily is
like devastating
but it's something to look for and again
let's talk about this a second queen d4
doesn't work i wonder why
i wonder why it's because of this rook
in that case you would be facing bishop
takes g6
and the wrath of my rook on d1
that's why people develop their rooks
first
and then look for active play on the
other side
rook d7 and
so far sakes was putting up
great resistance
there were multiple ways of winning
against queen d4
but i was just trying to pinpoint you
why it is important to bring your rookie
in the game
as early as possible now rook d7
and here success is putting pressure on
that d4 pawn and seemingly
everything's all right everything is
fine
if you go h4 then there's rook takes d4
and we get a fight
however whenever we talk about
isolated pawn structures we have to
remember a famous tactical idea
and that's pawn to d5
e takes d5 bishop f5 and
you'd think hey that that's just the
pawn for free
but it's far from the truth d5
not closes in
the queen and rook but completely
shuts this bishop out of the game which
is very important
he takes bishop f5 rook e7
and with this bishop sort of
misplaced we get time to do
our business on the king side now
kasparov played h4
queen c7 and kasparov kind of realized
hey i get it i could go for the attack
but even the end game is good for me
because once i blockade this pawn
i will get the advantage so it took took
rookie one
getting both of those rooks on the file
and one of the
side notes that i did want to mention
regarding this game then oftentimes
people underestimate
the strength of the bishop pair for one
thing
this pawn on d5 is going nowhere it's
just a weakness
nothing more now
black sort of things that white just has
compensation nothing more
maybe something like knight e4 could
make some sense
trying to bail
in the position however sakis
is sticking to the pawn but with these
two bishops
there's always enough compensation
however winning this position ain't that
easy
so how can we improve our positions as
white
remember you've got to keep being
active once you lose the initiative
there goes the advantage
h5 doesn't make that much sense in this
position because if you go here i'll
capture
capture knight takes h5 not only do you
give up a pawn
you're also attacking when there are no
queens on the board
which kind of diminishes the chances of
you winning the game
reroute the night that sounds like a
plan
but where
d4
so in the words
of the attacking player
forward kasimir go knight b5
hit the a7 pawn kind of provoking some
weaknesses and get this knight to d4
and once you block that pawn this bishop
will be shot in
forever and who wants to be shut in
forever
rookie 8 who takes c7 knight e7
bishop h3 obviously not giving up
the gam of the position the bishops
and hebrew success plays bishop c8
which sort of translates into an end
game
takes takes c8 knight a7
and you can see how like the positions
transform
first kasparov had the initiative gave
up a pawn
and once he realized that hey okay i can
give my bishop pair up but in change of
that
i will get the advantage and the
majority
on the queen side then i'll go for that
one
look c2 b4 king f8
bishop e3 and here circus
sort of collapses probably knight d7
would have been a bit more stubborn
but after not f5 takes ships c5
k8 knight b5 the game is completely lost
there's a big d-pawn and the a-pawn will
start running
down the board so observe tries to stop
it
but the knight c3 takes knight d5
f6 b5 this b pawn
is unstoppable after rook b3 b6
because spar of one has black resigned
the game so you can see
that you do have to follow some chess
principles
in order to build up a really hefty
attack
but
what is very very important is
to realize that
you can't really get this initiative out
without that
like you need to get
get it all built up so the attack will
go through
meanwhile i see breaking news
as the saint louis archbishops became
the 2020 champion
of the protest league it happened
it happened so congratulations
to the team to caruana dominguez
wesley and jeffrey john wow
cause sparrow wins the singles
archbishops win
we all win and that is fantastic news
great to hear that
i guess there's no better way to end the
stream
than say congratulations
and thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you